نعم نعم هل تسمعني نعم اسمع تفضل اذا
ضربات صاروخيه من شمال قطاع غزه الان مزيد
من الرشقات الصاروخيه فوق نتيفه عشره
ويبدو ان هنالك رشقات ودفعات صاروخيه
متتاليه من المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه
الان تستهدف بتيفا عسراء ومنطقه زكيم
والساحل الجنوبي لعسقلان لا يبدو ان القبه
الحديديه تعترض هذه الصواريخ الان اطلاقا
يبدو ان بعضها ايضا بعيد المدى
هناك الان الان فوق منطقه الجنوبيه
لعسقلان ذوي صافرات الانذار
واعتراضات بالجمله لكثير من الصواريخ
فوقنا تماما لبيت انتبه
اعتراضات صاروخيه مباشره فوقنا
علينا ان نحتني قليلا سفيان بالفعل رشقات
صاروخيه هائله
ومتتاليه من فوقنا الان
وبعض الاعتراضات الصاروخيه تحديدا في
المنطقه الجنوبيه
لعسقلان هذه الرشاقات الصاروخيه الكثيفه
لم نشهدها طيله هذا اليوم وبالتالي واضح
بان المقاومه الفلسطينيه هي التي تحدد
الموعد الذي تريده من اجل تسديد هذه
الضربات الصاروخيه كنا نشاهد سفيان في
الدقائق الاخيره بان السلاح الجو اسرائيلي
كان يسدد نتيف 10 لبيب نضيف عصره
هناك
اذا المزيد من الصواريخ فوق منطقه نتيفا
عصرا واياد مردخاي المواقع هذه ضربت
بكثافه في الدقائق الاخيره الان ايضا فوق
اصدارات يبدو ان هنالك سيكون اعتراض فوضى
فوق اياد مردخاي الان نشاهد هذا الاعتراض
من فوقنا تماما في منطقه يدمر دخاي ودوي
صافرات الانذار سفيان فعلا تدوي في كل
الارجاء هنا وبالكثيف من الصواريخ ربما
يكون هو هو بالفعل وبالتاكيد الاعنف هذا
اليوم والاقوى هذا اليوم والاشمل والاهم
والقبه الحديديه يعني تحاول الاعتراض هذه
الصواريخ من من اماكن عده بعض المنصات
الموضوعه في مدينه ازديرات وبعضها في
المناطق الجنوبيه لمدينه عسقلان لكن واضح
لان الرشاقات الصاروخيه كانت كثيفه وكنت
اود ان اقول سفيان ان هذه الرشقات وهذا
الوابل الكبير يد على قدره المقاومه
الفلسطينيه رغم كل الضغط الذي تصبه
اسرائيل وسلاح جوها على المناطق الشماليه
لقطاع غزه منذ ساعات الصباح
واستمعنا كنا نسمع لغارات جويه عنيفه في
المناطق الشماليه كانت تستهدف ربما مواقع
ومرابط هذه
المنظومات الصاروخيه التابعه للجهاد
الاسلامي لكن واضح بان لدى المقاومه ما
زالت القدره الهائله
والمتواصله والمستمره وفق الزمان والمكان
الذي تريده وهي تسدد هذه الضربات
الصاروخيه الان باتجاه مدينه عسقلان
تحديدا